une yourte peut bien fabriqué au coeur
de mariage
simple c'est la nouvelle résidence
secondaire de marie pour sa retraite
cette soixante huitarde a décidé de
quitter le plus souvent possible sa
cuisine équipée parisienne pour cette
source de 20 m² beaucoup de nature un
petit air de mongolie et un intérieur au
final plutôt cossu mari vient ici
quelques semaines de temps à autre mais
elle ne s'est pas transformé pour autant
en apôtre d'une vie 100% rustique il ya
une certaine satisfaction à réinventer
le chauffage bricoler bon tout ça c'est
très hypocrite parce qu'en fait on se
passerait absolument pas de sa femme et
se donnait son sentiment de temps en
temps comme peu on peut on peut vivre
sans qu'on n'ait pas aliéné à téléphone
mari n'est pas la seule à avoir succombé
aux charmes de cette drôle de tentes
dans laquelle des mongols le four de bon
sens 40 sur se sont vendus cette année
fait 4000 euros on vous la livre en kit
après il n'ya plus qu'à la montée tout
simplement
dans un autre registre m du sol la
cabane admirer la propriété normande
ils adorent leur ira pas jusqu à lyon où
santé un oiseau est presque parce que
c'est tellement vous serez vous m du
côté d'apple on sent le vent on a
vraiment impressionné les airs et oui
c'est donc à 20 de nos attentes en
mettant beaucoup plus solide donc en
beaucoup plus cher une cabane la famille
l'aurait cru